-Finally, yesterday was
Manatee Appreciation Day.
A day for manatees.
Oh, dugo-ong.
This brings us
to a segment called
"One of My Writers
Explains a Joke."
[ Suspenseful theme plays
Hey, everybody.
I am joined now
by one of our writers,
who is social distancing,
like we all should be,
Ally Hord.
How are you, Ally?
-I'm good.
How are you doin', Seth?
-Good.
It's nice to see you.
I only see you
via the jokes you submit
and you submitted one
that yesterday was Manatee
Appreciation Day.
"Manatee Appreciation Day.
Oh, dugo-ong."
And can you just explain that,
real quick?
-Happily.
Okay, so you know how you ca
sort of sarcastically reac
to something that's kind o
not interesting by saying,
"Oh, do go on"?
-100%, I know that.
-Okay, great.
And so you know how there'
another sea cow species
very closely related to th
manatee, called the dugong
-I did not know that.
-Okay. Well, that explains
why you don't get the joke
I'm from Florida and that'
pretty much Wildlife 101.
The dugong and the manatee
are sister species.
-So, are you saying that,
if you had been in Florida
when you heard it was
Manatee Appreciation Day
and said to a roomful
of Floridians,
"Manatee Appreciation Day.
Oh, dugo-ong,"
they would've laughed?
-Yes.
Like the Everglades
would've been rolling
in the aisles.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, you know,
one of the many benefits
of having a Floridian
on the writing staff
is getting that kind of
hyper-regional humor
from you, Ally,
so I just wanna say thank you.
I miss you.
Everybody give it up
to Ally Hord, a writer
who just explained a joke.
-Bye. Thank you.
[ Laughing ] Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "One of My
Writers Explains a Joke."